so we are these social media team of the  parking Department hillsdale college and  our boss vp of Hillsdale College  challenged us to do the ALS ice bucket  challenge even though were the last  people in America to do it we're still  going to challenge Michael Clarke the  third floor north of Simpson and the  entire social media intern team to do  the ice bucket challenge as well now we  could find ice in Michigan so we're  going with liquid nitrogen said okay  also another important thing to note we  are donating to the non stem cell  research for ALS so I don't not sure  which organization that is John Paul I  believe has one so just to be clear  that's the one we're going to be  donating an final thing special thank  you to dr. chris hamilton of the  chemistry department the hills are  called you think this is cool you should  take a class in chemistry absolutely all  right here we go three two one i right  leg you can see why  yeah my pants are frozen  you